know what else what's the smile on my
face after sura jina king is three-time
Emmy Award winner and she's been
entertaining audiences on television and
film forget this more than three decades
I've been loving it all three decades
well Sunday night was a huge night for
King she earned her first Golden Globe
Award for Best Supporting Actress in a
motion picture it was for the new Barry
Jenkins film if Beale Street could talk
in her acceptance speech King pledged to
help change Hollywood he called one of
the best speeches of the night the film
if Beale Street could talk is based on
the 1974 book by James Baldwin the story
follows two young lovers Tish and Fani
this feature is in jeopardy after fawni
is in prison for a crime he did not
commit King plays the matriarch her name
is Sharon rivers and in this clip she
just told fontys family that her
daughter Tish is expecting a baby a
child is coming it's not grandchild I
understand you
it's your grandchild what difference
does it make how it gets here
the child I got nothing to do with that
ain't none of us got nothing to do with
that
that child
Regina King good morning to you we're
getting rave reviews here your
performance in that movie and I know you
read the book and you said you read the
screenplay but it seems to me that you
really felt you knew this woman Sharon
Rivers you know this wife this girl
absolutely absolutely she's kind of an
amalgamation of all the women in my life
I'm blessed enough to come from a family
that that's how we get through
everything love and support and I think
so many of us in the world
mirror that same reality so I knew her
yeah Neuer you know I know her yeah you
talked about the impact that this movie
had on your son I want you to talk about
that but I also want you to address the
impact it had on your own mother hmm
you know she was it's so funny because I
got to talk to her
I was something before the Golden Globes
and she the movie had just it just got
to Cincinnati and she was just so proud
to be able to take 11 people and just
she recognized my grandmother herself in
the performance in the movie recognize
our family and she just kept saying I'm
just so proud baby I'm just so proud and
you just you know warms your heart to
have your mom say that because at the
end of the day I think most of us you
know you never want to disappoint your
mom I don't know and I love my mom so
much she's an amazing woman and I've
always felt like if like if I could be
half the mother she is I'm doing okay so
um I think I'm doing okay in this film
the family and the mom are what get them
all through I mean it's a survival and
resiliency in this situation where Fani
is totally railroaded and has to end up
not to spoil it but and and it's if it
weren't for the family everything would
fall apart absolutely and I think that
that's one of the beautiful things about
this story the James Baldwin was
is enough to make sure that it was a
partnership between Joe and Sharon yeah
you know so often we see these stories
and the father the patriarch isn't there
and you get to see that love between a
father and his daughters between him and
another father and that's important for
us to see because we don't get to see it
but we do live at an experience and to
that point though you made a point at
the New York Film Critics award I've had
the honor of introducing you but here we
are in a predominantly white room and
you made a point of saying to the white
audience even though this is a black
cast please don't think of this as a
black movie yes this is an American
movie why did you want to make that
point because I'm I think so often just
we judge things just by what we see of
me immediately and you look at this
beautiful billboard or poster and just
assume that it's not a story for you he
said it's an American story it isn't it
is an American story because look at
1974 is when James Baldwin work wrote
this book and we're still addressing
those same issues 45 years later yeah so
yeah that that's an American story
that's that's something that we have to
address as a country and I feel like at
the end of the day is it love Universal
yes is it pushing through every with the
support of your family Universal
absolutely so that's that's what I'm
your speech you gave it the golden oh
yeah I mean good idea about using that
platform to which is that speech in that
audience to say something more than just
about the role you've been acknowledged
for but about a value that you're
embracing why did you feel so strongly
about that and I went over the reaction
to it Here I am blessed with an
opportunity to have a platform that's
bigger than the average woman you know
and when I say average meaning that
she's a woman that's not in the public
side because there's nothing average
about women
so true yeah and while for a quick
second I wasn't sure what exactly I was
going to say but I knew that I needed to
take the the moment to say something at
a time when women are we are using our
voices and we are being heard that I
needed to shoot my shot yeah and and and
I did and the most amazing thing is as
soon as I walked off that stage the what
I started receiving from men you know
Tyler Perry is immediately after I got
off whatever whatever I need to do to
help you accomplish that emails from
Burt sake John levy casting director
that I've worked with before
Michael listo who's hired me as a female
director well Regina who did a call to
action and people you know and that's
where it starts no it just takes one
little as bianna pointed out you've been
in this game a long time it's amazing
you you have your head screwed on
straight you don't seem to have any
issues and you're just gorgeous and
still continuing yes yes Oscars my
favorite dress of the night to Bill
Street Beale Street kkatalk is playing
in select theaters now and opens
nationwide January 18th